there was a funny moment yesterday
during the michael cohen testimony
before the House Oversight Committee a
congressman a Republican congressman
mark Meadows used the black woman as a
prop okay he brought in a lone black
woman who worked for one of Donald
Trump's companies and said how can you
say Michael Cohen that Trump is racist
when here is a black woman who works for
Trump or worked for Trump and doesn't
think that Donald Trump is racist and
congresswoman Rasheeda Talib pointed out
that just because someone has a friend
who's black or an employee who's black
doesn't really mean that they're
necessarily not racist and meadows went
absolutely bonkers interrupting the
proceedings and saying I will not be
called the racist check out some of the
exchange you'll see here Meadows
ultimately making the case that hey he's
friends with Elijah Cummings who's black
and he also has a black niece so he
couldn't be racist let's start with
Rasheeda Talib who totally stumbles
through this moment and maybe it wasn't
even really the best point to try to
make completely bungles it but it's
still a fair point to make and then
things just explode from there just to
make a note mr. chairman just because
someone has a person of color a black
person working for them does not mean
they aren't racist and it is insensitive
that some would even say it's the fact
that someone would actually use a prop a
black woman in this chamber in this
committee is a lone racist in itself
Donald Trump is setting mr. Chairman I
ask I reclaim my time mr. chairman a
president mr. chairman office can be a
mr. chairman the rules are clear cover
up and hold on to business assets to
break campaign finance laws and
constitutional clauses what we have here
mr. chairman is criminal conduct and the
pursuit of the highest public office by
mr. Cohen an individual one I hope that
the gravity of this situation hits
everyone
this body and in Congress and across
this country
okay so then in comes meadows and he
starts discussing the comments with the
chairman of the Oversight Committee
Elijah Cummings and and the priority of
coasts of course of meadows is to just
prove how not racist a guy he is in
itself it is a racist act well I hope
not mr. chairman because I need to be
clear on this particular mr. chairman
mr. mr. meadows wait a minute I've
defended you and false as mrs. Meadows
I'm the chair yes sir you like you I
will clear this up now mr. Lee is it I
want to make sure I understand you did
not you were not intending to call mr.
meadows or races is that right no mr.
chairman I do not call mr. meadows at
racism
I am trying in the hotel the person of
color mr. chairman just to express
myself and how I felt at that moment and
so just for the record that's what was
my intention all right yeah
mr. chairman there's nothing more
personal to me than my relationship my
nieces and nephews are people of color
not many people know that you know that
miss mr. chairman and to indicate that I
asked someone who is a personal friend
of the the Trump family who is work for
him who knows this particular individual
that she's coming in to be a prop it's
racist to suggest that I asked her to
come in here for that reason mr.
president
the president's own person okay so
Meadows does a really good job of trying
to show how not racist he is because
he's friends with the chairman who's
black and he has people of color in his
family and argues that it's actually
racist to suggest that what he did was
racist and it all explodes in his face
because video has now been uncovered of
Mark meadows suggesting that President
Barack Obama be sent back to Kenya here
is a speech mark Meadows in 2012 running
for Congress in North Carolina's 11th
district
and he says it's time to send barack
obama back to kenya or wherever you know
it's it's interesting when the more we
find out the more we realize how wrong
the direction we're going and so what
we're gonna do is take back our country
2012 is the time that we're going to
send mr. obama home to kenya or wherever
it is we're going to do it so he's
suggesting sending the first black
president back to kenya or wherever he's
from but he would never use a black
woman as a prop pad that's something
that is just over the line and it's
completely offensive to even suggest
that yeah that's quite clearly a racist
comment although it doesn't stack up to
the dozens of racist comments that
Donald Trump has made so by that
comparison he's not doing so bad I guess
it's not even really necessary to find
this clip of Meadows saying send Obama
back to Kenya because again the argument
that you can't be racist because you
have a black friend or a person of color
niece or nephew
that's literal tokenism right that that
is that fits the definition of tokenism
which we're putting up on the screen for
our audience the practice of making only
a perfunctory or symbolic effort to do a
particular thing especially by
recruiting a small number of people from
underrepresented groups to give the
appearance of equality saying you have a
black friend in order to suggest that
there is equality in your mind in terms
of how you deal with people having one
black employee of Trump to suggest that
that is indicative of equality that is
the definition as an example of the
definition of tokenism and honestly
everybody came out of this thing looking
really bad Rasheeda Talib totally
bungled her statement ended up having to
clarify it it just really didn't look
good mark Meadows playing the I have a
black friend card also not looking good
and of course once he do a little bit of
research into him you realize he was not
long ago suggesting sending the first
black president of the United States
back to Kenya really really bad and the
level of discourse and desperation that
Republicans exhibited around these Cohen
questionings are absolutely embarrassing
they should all be embarrassed I send me
what your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show we'll take a quick break and
much more to discuss after this today's
show is made possible in part by Sun
basket giving everybody in our audience
60% off their first box when you go to
get Sun basket calms slash Pakman you'll
get six dinners delivered to your door
for just $28 Sun basket is a meal kit
service that brings fresh ingredients
for ready to cook recipes right to your
home but what separates Sun basket from
other meal plan services is Sun baskets
eco friendly food eco-friendly packaging
their commitment to organic ingredients
and their ability to fit almost any kind
of diet whether it's low-carb
gluten-free paleo vegetarian or vegan
pescetarian Mediterranean Sun basket
also has amazing meal plans even if you
don't have dietary restrictions just
choose what kind of meal plan you want
the number of recipes you want to
receive each week and Sun basket lets
you choose which individual recipes you
get before they're sent to you so you're
always getting something you love and
the recipes change every week you can
even choose when the meals show up at
your home you can skip weeks which is
also really convenient
everything arrives totally fresh all the
ingredients are pre measured so cooking
is a breeze and all of the recipes take
less than 30 minutes to make so it's
perfect for people with busy lives sign
up for affordable tasty healthy organic
eco friendly recipes brought straight to
your home ready to cook and save 60% off
your first week of meals when you go to
get Sun basket calm / Pakman 6 dinners
delivered to your door for just 28 bucks
I've put a link right underneath this
video